2021 was a big year for chinese leader
xi jinping at the communist party's
annual meeting this fall he was
symbolically elevated to the same status
as the people's republic of china's
paramount leader mao zedong by a rare
resolution backed by party members the
document laid out xi's understanding of
china's past and his vision for china's
future
president xi jinping hasn't left china
for nearly two years partly because of
the pandemic but also because he's
focused on building his legacy
in july ahead of the party's central
committee meeting he made it clear that
he's firmly in the driver's seat at home
and abroad
the chinese people will never allow any
foreign forces to bully oppress or
enslave us
anyone who dares try to do that will
have their heads bashed and bloodied
against the great wall of steel forged
by over 1.4 billion chinese people
this year marks the 100th anniversary of
the chinese communist party its official
history is the top item on the agenda
chairman mao zedong the founder of the
people's republic of china was the first
to enshrine his role as leader
[Music]
his successor deng xiaoping architect of
the reforms that propelled china's
economy to the world's second biggest
did the same
she wants to show that he's an equally
important leader transforming china into
a global power he wants to make his
power felt all across chinese society as
well he has boosted the military and
launched a crackdown that has muzzled
the tech tycoons like alibaba's jack ma
in recent weeks she has been stepping up
pressure on the sovereign island of
taiwan which china considers its own
but one challenge he has yet to overcome
is economic headwinds
growth is slowing amid an energy crunch
and supply chain disruptions
and there are still concerns about
china's real estate market
xi's image has become so elevated and so
sensitive that the communist party has
sought to curb all of their alternatives
beyond its officially crafted version of
who xi jinping is even to go so far as
to force the cancellation of a book talk
this october about xi in germany
the author of that book adrian gigas
told us then why he thinks china is
doing all this
what i'm feeling is and what they even
told us it's because you know there's
such a
cult of personality around xi jinping
now in china
and even to portray him as a human being
is too much i mean even to write
simple facts
he was divorced or something like this
we don't care about it we only mentioned
it in a sentence in the book even this
is too much because they will uh show
him in china as something like like a
superstar or even like like a god
and what she says goes his government
has pushed a number of reforms aimed to
erode individualism and push for more
devotion of the self to the state
that's shown up in the way china has
dealt with the pandemic ordering entire
cities to get tested vaccinated or go
into lockdown it's extended to the
bedroom with china's birth rate dropping
parents are being encouraged to have
more children video gaming for teenagers
now has a time limit and there's been a
clamp down on high-profile chinese
citizens anyone who comes across as
defiant of the state has been dealt with
harshly
as the world saw this fall with tennis
champion
pungshui to those living in china
pungshui is alive and well
but videos like this one released in
november didn't convince the wta
due to its continued concerns about
pung's well-being it withdrew all its
tournaments from china
its ceo saying in a statement
in good conscience i don't see how i can
ask our athletes to compete there when
pung shui is not allowed to communicate
freely and has seemingly been pressured
to contradict her allegation of sexual
assault
china meanwhile doubled down on its
stance suggesting a vendetta from the
west
hasn't responded to the allegations
but while china tries to block out the
issue the wta has been pushing for an
investigation
the decision to pull out of china was
its boldest step
helped by pong's success as a player
china accounts for hundreds of millions
of dollars for the women's tour
with the beijing winter games just ahead
the international olympic committee is
under pressure to do more
a 30-minute video call it held with pung
didn't assuage concerns
it led to criticism that the ioc was
playing into china's hands
with human rights watch calling it a
quote hostage video in a recent dw
interview the ioc you know let's think
about it this way if if you know you're
asked to participate in making you know
helping make a hostage video
do you
jump in and say yes no of course you
don't you try to find ways to actually
assist the person not protect your own
reputation which is all the ioc is doing
here
pong has received support from many
current and former tennis players who
have praised the wta's decision
one question now is whether other sports
bodies will follow that lead